um is a professor at university of
washington and also
at msr and uh
as you probably know sean has had lots
of work behind a lot of things in
machine learning
from policy iteration linear bandits
even latent variable models
and i'm really excited to hear from sean
today
trump are you around that great
all right uh we can see my screen
and my voice okay sweet uh so
again thanks to the uh both the
long-term organizers
of uh you know the rl workshop and
the organizers uh for this week because
it's it's just like it's super
stimulating uh and it's a great time to
have this and of course
uh always i'm giving a big thanks to
peter bartlett because
uh uh it's just a ton of work uh for him
so i'm excited to speak about some a
recent work with
rusong and dean on uh offline
reinforcement
learning so this is a good bridge to the
next workshop
actually because that's entirely on uh
offline
uh reinforcement learning rusan actually
is in the chat so if you have questions
feel free to
uh to either ask him or just go ahead
and
interrupt me and ask
okay so we can see it advancing just uh
okay great so uh so what is offline
reinforcement learning it's
uh basically the approach is to try to
utilize
uh offline or observational data to try
to help in learning
uh basically causal sequential decision
making strategies
it's becoming increasingly important now
particularly in a number of like high
stake applications just going beyond
games and things like that
we do have a lot of data
and in many settings it's actually
pretty hard to run causal experiments
and we'd like to really leverage
this this offline data
okay so
what are the challenges here so let's
consider
uh this uh this healthcare example as a
running example because it's i think
it's a little more compelling
uh so what are the challenges in this
space well we've got a sequential
decision making problem because the
decisions affect the future
uh as i said we can't many of these
settings uh we can't learn causal
experiments very easily or
because we just have the data offline
and a real concern might be
just not enough data in various
subgroups
and on top of that we've got this curse
of dimensionality where
effectively we have uh an infinite
possible set of configurations for the
type of people
that come in and we need to use some
kind of function approximation
uh to handle this issue okay so
so start let's just start simple and get
some intuition so we're all on the same
page
of when we agree offline learning is
okay
okay so this would be uh easy but uh
let's
it's definitely helpful to just be very
concrete see when
things are fine in fact let's make life
even simpler forget about
the sequential decision making aspect of
things
in that our decisions affect the future
let's just consider
the horizon 1 problem which is like a
bandit setting uh and it's still
sequential that we might be changing our
behavior
but the world itself there's no
sequential aspects uh to the world
there's no state
okay so uh consider a setting where you
know uh notation's gonna be
s is the state uh it could be all kinds
of patient characteristics
uh so there's effectively an infinite
number of possible states
uh we have an action space it could be
large could be small
and we have a reward function which uh
is some measure of the quality of the
outcome like how long it takes the
patient
to get better or some measure of how
well they're feeling
for this setting uh let's just go ahead
and think about one of the most commonly
used approaches which is we model
the outcome as a linear function of some
future vector of s and a
so if i is some d dimensional feature
mapping
and uh when does this work
okay so again there's no sequential
decision making
so when does this work so uh and when
does the uh
offline uh learning work here so so
we're gonna have a data set of endpoints
of
uh you know states treatments uh rewards
uh define sigma to be our future
covariance matrix
it's like a d by d matrix so let's make
two assumptions here
first is realizability so let's actually
suppose the linear model is correct
okay not just for our algorithms using
these features
let's actually suppose the linear model
is correct and let's suppose we have
this coverage property because
if we're going to do well we could
better see uh kind of all directions
of the data all directions of our
futures and that
and this coverage assumption is
literally a minimal eigenvalue
assumption on this covariance matrix
okay so if that's bounded away from zero
uh we've effectively seen all the
directions in our data okay and under
the
these two assumptions uh it's pretty
straightforward to convince yourself
that
uh provided we have uh you know
uh some amount of data scales with d
over epsilon squared
divided by lambda min uh what's nice
about this is we'll be accurate on
any new test point that's what this
realizability lets us do
not just on the distribution for which
our data is collected will be good on
any test point
okay and this lambda min is really
coming from a shift factor that we train
on one
distribution and we're tested on another
okay so uh so again this is just a
straight up regression but we're heavily
leveraging this realizability assumption
and note these are very strong
assumptions from the practical side
because
in a high state application we would
never believe these like we definitely
are very concerned about model
misspecification and all kinds of
sampling biases
so this is very much an abstraction in
this uh
in this setting but if we have it it's
easy
so now let's jump to the sequential
decision making setting
in a very small state example so
consider three states in this toy mvp
just set up some notation and then we'll
set up the problem so
a super simple problem a small number of
states
uh you know there's a user notation we
have transitions
we have rewards say that uh that are
bounded and we're going to get an
offline data set of end points except
now the offline data set
is a state action where we transition to
and the reward
okay so it's a quite uh quadruple
this that the the triple of sas prime
with the reward again our goal uh let's
make life easy let's
forget about even policy improvement
let's just say can we evaluate
how good a single policy is like a known
policy is
from the start state okay so we aren't
caring about improvement at all
we just want to evaluate a fixed policy
okay and uh you know one standard
approach is just do this
backward induction this fitted q
iteration so take your
offline data set uh and we want to
estimate the value of this policy pi
uh and we just move backwards with the
usual notation so q hat we just have to
be the empirical reward
and then you do these bellman-based
backups okay so
uh we're all familiar with this and when
does this work well
uh we know this is gonna work if our
data set
has a reasonable number of samples at
every state action pair
okay so this is just coverage because
it's a small problem
if we see every state action in our data
set uh
we'll be able to estimate the value of
the policy
accurately okay so so for this one
we need coverage and of course
this world is easy because the number of
state and actions are small
okay so now let's go back to say this
problem what we care about doing
okay so what we're going to try to do
which is what we do in practice is just
kind of merge these two ideas where
we're going to try to do some fit in
this backup procedure
and our hope is we're going to try to
avoid this 2 to the h
sample size because if we just tried
this naive thing on this tree
we're really going to have to see two to
the h samples before we can do anything
uh interesting because that's kind of
the cases
uh we might go to okay so we're trying
to
uh get some kind of guarantee that
doesn't depend on like the number of
configurations and the hope
is you know we've got these uh features
uh you know we're gonna think of a
setting we have some features these
features will hopefully help us
handle the cursive dimensionality uh
just like for regression
and just like regression we're going to
think about extending this coverage
assumption
where we think about our future
covariance matrices are going to somehow
be well conditioned at every level
okay we'll make this precise why
does this seem reasonable well uh
you know if we have the same assumptions
i showed you at the last level
regression would be fine
and from regression we know we're going
to be accurate at every
uh possible last stage configuration
right that was the whole point at every
possible configuration
regression's good and we might hope we
can use that to plug that into the
previous stage
and just do regression again because
that's one candidate algorithm
but more generally we might just care
about information theoretically what are
the limits like
you know a question really is what are
the information theoretic limits
of handling data reuse with function
approximation so not just this kind of
backup-based algorithm
what is achievable and in particular
what assumptions make certain
uh classes of you know what assumptions
will make this problem
uh uh what assumptions will allow
for sample efficient uh estimation of
the value of a policy
okay so specifically the talk will try
to understand
uh what are necessary kind of
representational and distributional
conditions
which will permit a sample efficient rl
okay and uh make life easy we'll just
focus on policy evaluation so we're not
going to worry about improvement we just
want to take our offline data set figure
out how well
uh how well we can actually estimate the
value
of a fixed policy okay and
the main result for the lower bound is
going to be showing that
the analogs of this realizability
assumption and coverage assumption
are definitely not enough for sample
efficient offline learning this is a
super
basic question and we'll try to give
some intuition for
why that's the case so this is pretty
uh depressing at some level
and from the upper bounds i'll discuss
some prior work here
where it's really showing we need much
stronger assumptions
for this to occur and uh also
uh discuss time permitting uh this
question of like how generic
is this issue of amplification like you
know like sure we construct some lower
bonds showing it's going to happen
do we really expect to see these effects
in practice and i think this is one of
the
the real questions uh we're thinking
about now
which is particularly relevant in
various high stake applications
okay so let's just uh
lay out the setting where we're working
with a linear value function
approximation there's an actual pointer
there's been a ton of work
on this in rl in the last few well
actually for
from quite some time ago but in terms of
the theory there's been a revival
looking at this and this is really
uh arguably the simplest case and to
attack this problem
uh it's you know it's just the natural
extension of regression
okay so the setting is going to be we
have some data collection distribution
mu and muh
and you know each stage this is giving
us the triples of an s
a s prime where the semantics are s
prime is drawn from the
underlying distribution reward is and
they're always drawn from the correct
distribution
and we're going to get some iid data set
from these distributions
okay and our goal is let's just evaluate
a single policy we know the policy we'd
like to estimate its value
so that's our goal okay so no
improvement here just
a policy evaluation okay so we're going
to
make these two assumptions precise
and then see what we can get okay so
assumption one is going to be
a bit stronger assumption than uh
realizability in that
okay so we assume we have a feature
mapping and you know the case we want in
practice is the dimension of this
mapping is smaller than the number of
states and actions we're going to assume
that
every policy so fix the policy or take
any policy you want
and there's going to exist a weight
vector
such that the q function is linear in
this weight vector
okay so this is for every essay pair in
the mdp
uh the q function is linear okay so uh
so this is for every policy
uh we have a linear state action value
okay so not just the
the one we're interested in so it is a
reasonably strong constraint
okay so uh and and you know sometimes
people refer to this as linear value
function approximation but it's it's
realizable
okay so the second assumption is you
know we kind of know what needs to
happen at h equals one which is
regression
which is we need coverage so uh just
assume your features are bounded
uh less than one that's without loss of
generality and let's go ahead and assume
the best possible
uh coverage in that in a spectral sense
so with respect to our data distribution
uh mu uh we're going to assume that a
future covariance matrix is one over d
times the identity
okay and that is the best possible
coverage because
you know this is the largest minimal
eigenvalue you can have
when your features are bounded by one
okay so this is kind of the
the best shaped uh covariance matrix
for covering all the directions so we're
going to go ahead and assume that
okay so we can't really at least in a
spectral sense we can't
hope for anything stronger
okay so are we good up to here so it's
just uh
you know all policies linear we have
coverage
uh from what we said before h equals one
is completely fine
okay because this is what we need for
regression to work
okay so
uh right so it's set uh so we set things
up in that
uh you know we've got our two nice
assumptions we've got realizability now
uh that's the hope is that's going to
handle the curse of dimensionality and
we've got future coverage
so we're kind of not missing these
missing cases
in some aggregate sense because
obviously we're missing cases but we're
not
missing directions because this phi has
aggregated
aggregated these cases again our
question now is
you know this is more intuition from an
upper bound perspective
but you know are these assumptions
somehow enough to allow us to move
backwards now
you know more generally we're interested
in if an information theoretic lower
bond here
but when you see this the obvious thing
to think about is can i just go
backwards because regression's going to
work
it's going to be accurate everywhere can
i plug this into
one previous step and keep moving
backward and will this
give me a good estimate of the value
so and you know i think those are
studied rl we always try things like
this
and we want to know uh will this work
okay so uh before we get to the main
result let's
uh look at upper uh what's known here
because it's
uh this has clearly been studied in
various
uh different incarnations so probably
the largest amount of work in the
settings
was uh with regards to important
sampling okay
and uh uh here you know we kind of know
that naively you need exponential and h
samples and
this broader set of um
offline rl uh using important sampling
it's kind of hard to
uh put function approximation in this in
this framework but you know that said
important sampling
is it's pretty honest and it works quite
well in practice but
it's pretty hard to get past this xh
barrier with it
because specifically on uh this setting
of
using linear value function
approximation we know if we have
stronger constraints
on the system we can do this so we have
this sort of policy completeness or
sometimes this is called
uh policy closure is better i've seen it
referred to as
a completeness too i don't know want to
use that one rather than closure but
basically this assumption says that if
we can back
up every uh possible weight vector so
take a weight vector can we back it up
then we can actually do offline rl
okay so uh and this is a stronger
assumption in the sense that
if we assume a policy completeness for a
given policy
that implies realizability for the
policy and if we assume
uh we can do this for all policies like
all policies are complete that implies
realizability
uh for all policies which is our
assumption a1 so this is definitely a
much stronger assumption
and if you think about it you can really
see precisely why
this uh really has
it really says something about the the
way the futures interact with the
dynamics
okay and recently uh you know there's a
bunch of work here uh chavo was one
of the earlier authors in a more general
setting but specifically for the case of
uh policy evaluation with completeness
there's a recent paper by duan
and mengi showing minimax rates here
with a stronger condition
and if you don't have this condition uh
you know there's a recent paper by nanji
showing that with stronger density ratio
lower bonds you can do it but all of
these are
significantly stronger conditions uh to
say anything here
okay and you know the question is like
look what's is possible here because
these other conditions are
substantially stronger than regression
so uh the main result for the lower
bound is you can't do this so take any
offline rl algorithm so this algorithm
is going to take a policy as input so it
knows the policy
it knows the feature mapping and it's
given a data set
so it knows this like gigantic table of
future mapping we don't care about
computation
okay and the point now is like if you
have coverage
uh you know there's going to exist an
mdp that's also realizable such that for
any policy a is going to require
you know d to the h 2 samples uh to
estimate
the value of this policy okay so
basically you've got realizability and
coverage and you can't estimate the
value of
any of the policies in the mdp
you're not just one just you're given
some policy we can't estimate
the value of any of them okay so every
policy here has a linear value
information theoretically we can't
estimate a single one of them
okay so that's the main lower bound uh
i'll
have time here okay so uh
let's make some comments uh about this
and interpret things
because i think this has a number of uh
interesting implications
so uh so let's make some observations so
uh i believe this is the statement clear
basically you're just doomed here under
these assumptions uh
in a pretty strong sense okay so
uh so so let's just jump to some uh
observations can i ask a quick question
you're often in this setting i guess
you're simulating a particular policy
so you can at least estimate that one
yeah
do you think it is important here that
you're not no it isn't like
so we have some comments in the paper
this yeah like in this case you can you
can definitely get the value
if you have your trajectories of that
one uh but most of them you still can't
get
so we we have this comment in the paper
the fact that
uh uh we haven't kind of given the data
set from
one policy is trajectories it doesn't
make a difference it
it's more to emphasize how severe this
problem is but we directly handle this
other one and morally like
most of them you're still burned on hey
hey sean
i have a related question uh with dan
is uh what's the significance of like
the impossibility to do this for
like all policies right because if i
think of naively like if i copy my
action
for each state if i copy my actions like
multiple times then
if i can't do anything with any one
policy like all the policies are the
same thing so
i cannot evaluate anything right come
back to that one later so
uh the significance of that short is
that for lower bonds
uh we want to put more constraints on
the system so
constraining the problem to be linear in
all policies is a much stronger
constraint on the system than one of
them
that's the so i can come back to that
later so let me just uh proceed because
i want to
share some experiments too okay so a
couple of quick comments
uh you know there's clearly a separation
between rl and supervised learning in
this office line setting because like
regression is fine here at h equals one
okay a pretty puzzling thing here is
this
something called this algorithm of doing
backups plus regression least squares
policy evaluation lspe
so this is doing regression plugging
things in so this is surprising because
uh you get an unbiased estimator here
like
this is when we started doing
experiments like if you think about this
regression's unbiased
you actually get an unbiased estimator
here it just happens it has it'll have
exponential variance
okay and what's interesting about this
uh lower bond construction it's super
simple
it's an mdp with only dh states and two
actions
so the online problem is trivial to
solve
like uh it's not like some gigantic mdp
like some of these other lower bonds
that we have it's a very small
mdp uh it's it's a little bigger than
the number of states but like trivially
okay and uh you know those of us working
in this
we always see this geometric error
amplification
uh even under realizability in our
analysis and in practice
we see it too and i'm not going to
discuss the construction too much but i
definitely recommend people
to look at the paper just because okay
let me put it this way like
i wished i had read this construction
years ago because
uh like we keep doing analysis and every
time we keep seeing this amplification
and even if you don't care about like
this offline problem it's helpful to see
concretely
how this amplification can occur for a
given algorithm because
it this comes up so often in analysis
and it it's a very simple
like gadget to be used in like other
lower bonds or upper bounds and coming
up with cases where things go
uh where things go wrong so it's
actually a very simple construction
which i think really highlights how bad
things are okay so uh i do have a couple
of minutes uh left
um and i think i started a couple of
minutes later so let me just
make a few comments about uh upper
bounds and how
uh worst case this is like how generic
is this
error amplification say you know we gave
this lower bound for
information theoretically but uh you
know for upper bounds like what's going
to happen if we did dominant backups
plus regression
okay on real problems like how
pathological is this so so we know it
can occur
uh but on the other hand like look if
it's tabular
or if you consider a case where the
number of states is the dimension
this will not occur so some cases it
absolutely does not occur
like because regression plus backups in
the tabular case
there will be no amplification okay so
so in a sense like what cases is this
actually
occurring for okay and before we even
actually did anything uh like formally
figured out this little one we just
tried it and
this was either like the second or the
first thing we tried
we just had massive error amplification
so the x-axis is the level
uh it's kind of going backwards so at
level 100 that's the last level
and we're plotting here the l2 error in
estimating the weights with this
backup algorithm and uh you know i'll go
through the
example a little more precisely but you
see like
uh you know it's not a log plot here so
it's like ten to the minus six
everything's bounded between zero one it
blows
up to ten thirty and this is like
literally just
some construction we cooked up uh when
we sang was trying it out like all of us
independently like wait a minute
this algorithm is unbiased what's
actually gonna happen and then the
second thing we tried is like
just explosion okay so um
you know so specifically let's look at
this uh least squares policy evaluation
which is
use bellman backups with plug-in
estimates
uh let's um just so here's a very
helpful way to think about things
with inequality so we've got n data
points
define phi to be your future matrix
which is of size n by d so this
concatenate all your data into your
future
matrix define phi bar to be your next
state feature matrix which is
where you go to from sa
okay and let epsilon be the noise in the
reward vector so
you know the reward you observe is the
true reward plus a little noise
okay why this is nice why we want to
look at phi bar
is suppose w hat h is what our weight
vector is at level h
okay so the prediction of the values is
phi bar w hat h because
if you think about it for h minus one
we're going to be plugging in
uh some target when we do a regression
so at h minus one
that goes to level h and we're doing a
regression we're using
you know what comes in to back up at h
minus one
and what's are we going to use for
estimate we're going to use where we go
to
times our estimated weight so phi bar h
times w hat
h is like the regression targets we're
plugging in this algorithm
because uh right because at h minus one
we're going to take our basis
uh try to regress where we go to at the
next level
okay and the main point i want to make
here is because you're just doing these
regressions
you can just with an exact equality
unravel
what the estimator looks like and you
see it's like a product of a bunch of
matrices so if you can see my cursor
you know this is like the xx transpose
this is x so forget about everything
past here if this was y
this would be regression this is xx
transpose this would be x y
okay but why is the thing coming from
the next level so you plug that in and
you kind of keep unraveling this object
and you get this equality and what's
nice about this is like look the
qualities are great
so uh and and i'm assuming that we have
a deterministic mdp and all the noise is
coming from
uh the reward right so so this means
like you know we know exactly how this
algorithm's gonna behave
because we can fix these matrices for
the deterministic mdp case we can see
what happens
okay and it literally just boils down to
uh some non-expansive property of this
product of matrices
and and now the issue is you just
massage them so we give you know in the
paper
a sharper condition for when it doesn't
explode in terms of distribution
uh shift it's sharper than when what nan
has but that's only because we're doing
policy evaluation
okay and this paper by duane shows that
completeness works and you can also show
it's non-expensive
let me take like two more minutes and
i'll just show you some quick
experiments but at the end of the day
you have inequality
now you can start trying things so uh
you know we can simulate an mdp we just
cooked up like a simple chain mdp that
you know the states just don't interact
they just fall all the way down
uh we you know it's a sparse mdp
we make it complete for a policy by just
taking the true
uh q value and add extra features so it
definitely
contains uh the future vector of the
collec the correct one
this dashed block is we take the first
2d
guys to be the basis that the algorithm
sees so we've got coverage we've got
realizability for this policy
and it's deterministic we put a super
tiny amount of noise of 10 to the minus
10.
again we say does do we get
amplification
okay so we try this no okay so the same
plot
uh you do uh level by rewards it's like
10 to the minus 10 you see no
amplification you could look at that
frobenius norm
of that mess of products a matrix no
application
okay let's modify this a bit and instead
we're going to make our basis to be
uh rather than d of them we're going to
say our data set is coming from
rather than 2d a data so it's going to
come from a smaller set
of points but it's still basically well
conditioned
a small amount of noise i can take you
through some questions later if you're
interested in
this but it's just a modification of the
previous example
where we choose a smaller number of
points in our offline data set but it's
still like very well conditioned
a super tiny amount of noise do the same
experiment again
massive amplification okay and uh
the product so this is again h by our
air this is h and this is the
forbiddenious norm of this product and
it explodes and it's very easy to get
examples like this so the main point
like i'm making here let me just wrap
things up
is that uh um you know you can look at
the talk for these examples or email us
us but like look this offline problem
it's information theoretically
we can't do it with coverage and uh
realizability alone
we definitely need stronger conditions
i think it's worth uh pointing out why
this is important in that
for like these important applications we
really do need to take a fair bit of
care
because look even in the short horizon
problem
it's already hard due to model
mis-specification sampling biases
because like
our modeling assumptions aren't correct
and we really care a lot
about this because you know if you're
doing treatments and things like that
okay and uh when we move to h equal
bigger than one the sequential decision
making setting
the situation is substantially worse
because under the same set of
assumptions
in the best case scenario it might not
even work without stronger assumptions
okay and that's pretty concerning
okay and i think once you start playing
around with it it's very easy
to get error amplification in some cases
like without these stronger assumptions
uh if you start touring around with it
you really will see
uh error amplification and more
importantly there's a quality like it's
inequality it's very helpful
it's a quality for an algorithm but
what's becoming clear when we try it out
is that our upper bounds are also quite
loose too that a better check
is looking at uh you know the way these
matrices behave
because there's other cases where we
don't see it in other cases
we do and we really need to kind of look
more carefully about the actual behavior
of regression to see what's going on
but i think there's a strong reason to
believe that
to get this to work we really do need
like better features and if we just do
the
usual machine learning thing kind of
pick up some feature set we think it's
okay
i think we're going to see amplification
and this is joint with uh
work with dean foster who's a good
friend of mine a statistician
and uh uh ru seong wang who's been doing
awesome work
we were just doing a bunch of work
together in this broader context of
trying to understand
uh what are the conditions we need what
are the kind of representational
conditions we need
for uh for effective reinforcement
learning more generally and yeah like
results
just been doing great work in in this
space so thank you very much
and i'm happy to take some more
questions
thank you shaw it's a great talk really
surprising do you have an intuition for
any sufficient conditions where
amplification will not happen
yeah so in a sense like these are the
two uh um
i mentioned from like others that
uh sufficient conditions are
this sort of low distribution shift and
what that means
is that uh the product of
this basically phi bar has to look a bit
like phi
in a spectral sense there's a more
precise version of that
but uh that's one and another
is this policy completeness that for
kind of every
weight vector uh somehow
it has a certain projection property you
can write it in terms of the matrices
but there's a certain projection
property that the infinity norm
basically doesn't expand
okay it's like you know they write it
differently but you can verify
that the completeness condition which is
saying that you know
every q value lives that you know every
possible w.5
when you back it up lives in the space
of i then that works too so these are
sufficient conditions
but the main point i want to mention is
because of this equality
these sufficient conditions don't really
capture what's going on
because we've definitely can come up
with cases like we've just been
you know doing random features to kind
of cook up this problem
but forcing realizability so you can
always start with a true q vector and
add features
because then you'll always have
realizability and we can definitely see
cases where
these cases aren't sharp and i think the
moral of the story here
is that you know in a real high stake
application this product of matrices
it's kind of like an important sampling
ratio but in future space like you could
actually just
literally rather than doing important
sampling
you could literally just compute this
spectral amplification
and if it's occurring you know you're
burned right so rather than kind of
doing important sampling
this seems like a much better way to
kind of control
which policies you can actually estimate
because this is an honest equality
i suggest something different hey sean
uh so i think this is a great hug and i
like the work a lot and as i already
discussed
a lot with russell and eu so uh
i think so since you're talking about
policy evaluation in the offline case
i want to contrast this with some of the
like the possible results
not the one that you mentioned you know
for policy optimization
i decided but you actually cite the
other paper of a recent paper
for policy evaluation and i think just
to in a practical sense
policy evaluation with realizable coup i
is actually
i would say practically feasible uh and
i think to to contrast with the result
you have here and all the
great intuition you're building up i
think there are two things
a maybe we're aiming at the wrong goal
of accurately estimating the precise
performance two maybe we're using the
wrong algorithm that we're doing this
backup
so it turns out that you know a lot of
us recently so first of all in terms of
algorithm a lot of us originally are
looking at these algorithms that does
moment matching
you know but this is the information
theoretic yes i know i know yes yes so
that's
my second point so the possible result
we get is that instead of we can
estimate the point estimate
we give you an interval that could be
loose but sometimes it's
tight but when it's loose you do see it
so this is in the sense like similar to
what you're saying here like as
checking c times c bar it's like when
you fail
you know you failed yeah so that's right
so you can just look at this matrices
but but that's
but that's not saying that it it works
this is the same like important sampling
yeah it doesn't work you just get valid
intervals right
but my point is that a i think i'm
recently more and more convinced that
for our policy policy evaluation i would
never use these backup methods
what i would do instead is do these like
moment matching methods
that check the uh essentially you want
to optimize the current value and the
future value like together
you never want to fix future value and
then optimize the next
value look no you're not you're going to
have the
like amplification effects because i
like i can look at the moments and i can
do it
get exactly the same kind of issue
because what's going to happen when you
match movements is your intervals there
are going to be getting pushed through
these amplification matrices
and and you like you literally can see
this if you think of the moment
matching thing because you're going to
say some phi dot w is like
matched to something that w is getting
pushed through some matrix
that next one is push to sum matrix and
that's exactly this
uh this product that comes up in a
slightly modified sense
and the issue is still in some cases
you're okay
but those cases uh you actually you know
they're much stronger conditions when
this when this occurs now i think the
point
that we you know under realizability
will have confidence bonds i
think i think this is a very good point
because
uh because in practice like that means
there is something better to do here
than important sampling
and i think that's actually quite
valuable because now you could
try to you know at least compare things
in some
interval but that interval uh
is uh you know like my
my claim again this is more uh intuition
playing on these experiments
my feeling is that interval is only
going to be reasonable
if we have better features like and and
and getting those better features
is not at all obvious how that's going
to happen like actually i talked about
some of those things
but those features really have
properties about how
those features get pushed through your
dynamics matrix
because that's like so i think some i
think maybe what i'm talking about the
the methods we're talking i'm talking
about
still different sites different from the
moment matching thing you're talking
about
so basically what we have is like if you
have q pi in q
that's the only condition you have you
always have a valid interval
but as you said like sometimes maybe
this interval just too loose to be any
meaningful at all
yeah but uh under some conditions
some of the sufficient conditions you
mentioned like these intervals will be
sufficiently small
but i think the point which is similar
to your idea of checking fee times c bar
here is that
it's still nice enough that you know at
least when we fail we know we failed
so yeah say that
can i ask uh so what was the second
question here for me sorry but the
so i i think i get the intuition for why
this works for
for why lspe has this um exploding
variance
but is there sort of a similar intuition
for why this is inherent to any
algorithm
yeah it is how does that construction
work yeah so this is why like i wish i
had a little more time to show this
because
i feel like this construction is just
helpful
it was kind of the gadget that chaba
uses too in their like
linear q star paper but it's
uh because it's information theoretic
and like you know when we when we do
this we see the amplification
basically what's happening is um
at the last level uh you're gonna have
like a reward which is like
d to the minus h over two or zero like
there's two cases okay so it's like a
super tiny and obviously you can't tell
the difference between them
okay and like in the next level uh so
you're estimating something that's super
tiny
okay so you've got the states here
you're estimating it's super tiny and
then
uh there's a reward here which is value
is going to be root b
times as big as the value of these guys
because uh your weight vector can be
like the all ones vector
okay so somehow uh because basically you
can show by linearity
you know you've got a standard basis e1
ed you get all of them
like not very accurate okay but then
there's one guy that's gonna have like
root the
i mean this is again the lspe well this
is the truth like this guy has
a value which is root d times each of
these guys values
and the point now is you can't estimate
this guy's value so you lose here
and then you can kind of nest this but
the key in this
construction is somehow you can do this
in a way that
you get no information about the system
aside from the last level
where there's basically an exponentially
small gap
so somehow you miss the gap and
you you know the the process keeps
amplifying the high reward signal keeps
kind of
moving to this high reward state so i
think with that just look at this
picture
but it really sharply shows like what
goes wrong with lspe but
i felt like that construction i was like
oh my god like
it just shed a lot of light of how we're
seeing
this amplification in every upper bound
analysis
uh we try but it's it is pretty simple
but it's basically just that
uh you know with it with a couple of
dollars in muscles
thank you yeah hi
uh i uh i had a query uh um
with respect to the uh assumption two uh
if you can uh go back to the slide
yeah sure uh
here uh yeah
uh but yeah uh here we have the uh
one by d that's the identity uh uh
and do we use the um minimum eigenvalues
here
to satisfy our
expectation r
because this uh yeah because this
condition
uh phi s uh comma a
um less than one should be
ah so for all
s a uh we have we're assuming this
yeah yeah so this is the largest
possible minimum eigenvalue you can have
okay okay okay basically i just want
something that's like
well condition and i'm you know this is
the best possible condition i'm just
saying the condition number
is uh d and that's the best possible you
can have in d dimensions
okay okay that's very low
like you would hope that you're poly in
the condition number but we just set it
up to be
like the best possible conditioning um
okay thanks yeah
so hey sean i have a question i i wonder
if you have any like perspective on this
um
you know there's a setting where like
all your features live in a convex hull
and your data distribution is on the
vertices of the hull
so now i think you can't have error
amplification
yeah because you do like a l1 geometry
instead of l2 geometry right yeah
so i'm wondering if you have any like
like perspective or like
i don't know like conceptual points
about this like uh the
usual perspective is the favorite
inequality koshi shorts uh holder like
basically uh you know all as far as i
can like all of these things you're just
gonna koshi shorts it
uh uh differently for uh for what's
going on here
so uh but i'm thinking maybe more about
like
like practical considerations like what
if i
create features in such a way that this
is the case maybe it becomes much harder
to satisfy realizability but i like
avoid this error amplification
my concern uh so i right so uh and i
have been like
thinking about practice and what's going
on the main concern yeah so my intuition
for like
features on the simplex uh this concern
this is not um
you know like i would be much more
impressed if
you could do it with like an l2 norm
rather than out because basically you
have no capacity
on the simplex so and if you're really
lying
on like the weights being bonded in one
norm in some sense which is what's going
to be the case
it's effectively just saying you can use
one of those features like if you could
do two
then i would be impressed here and
that's not going to happen here so
there's a very real sense in which
that constraint in practice is uh
it's it's very it's very limiting
uh i think and and uh
like you know we can't kind of make it
uh like a simplex and two when you scale
things quickly we can kind of slightly
increase the size of that simplex and
that's the part i'm concerned about so
i'm
kind of be much more motivated with the
stuff that you're trying to do like
actually
try to get features which are robust to
these um
to these kind of amplification effects
but you know more broadly the intuition
is yeah it's like just stare at this
equation and it's a product of matrices
but it becomes increasingly clear
they're cases that aren't complete or
um the glue sign was just running these
experiments for a while and like
yeah you don't get completeness or you
don't get the shift condition
but you don't get amplification but it's
very brittle
to get it as well so uh
you know so this question of like how to
get those features yeah i think this is
a great question but it does feel like
uh it it has something to do with the
interaction of the
the p matrix and the phi uh
um yeah and that's the thing that we
just don't really know how to
uh today aside from the stuff you were
tired i was the only kind of case where
we actually learned something
uh learn those features
uh so uh follow up uh can we have a sort
of
uh ols here
uh with respect to uh the
uh the um lease
square policy iterations and how can we
compare that to this
uh how can you compare what uh well yeah
uh ols or uh the uh
least uh square policy iterations
oh uh
so i'm not sure if i'm totally
understand the question so so this is
basically ols
okay and policy iteration we're going to
a harder question now of actually trying
to improve things
right and that's why i think it's
helpful to separate those two things uh
apart so like nan's work and charbra's
earlier work
gives conditions when a policy
improvement
will work uh but sort of riffing on when
nan says
uh you know if we can't evaluate a
single one of them
uh we're doomed so so you could think of
like the sharp way of doing this
uh i think i'm getting at your question
would be to
try to figure out how accurate uh
each policy is being estimated before
you do the update
um but the concern is like you know if
your features aren't good you're just
gonna
get burned immediately and then you're
back to like lower distribution shift
yeah yeah totally agree yeah
thanks for watching experiments
uh and then i just want to have one
small request for experiments
so besides lste uh i really really
really want to see
how lstd which is this classical
moment matching based methods work in
all these different settings
i think my my prediction
what there's no difference like no no
they'll be
no i think their their behavior will be
very different
i mean in any case i want to see those
we're doing a longer empirical study so
we'll ping you on that so the reason is
that
you're just doing an l2 constraint on
the w's
and and the point is see every time
you're doing the constraint
there's a matrix between how you're
getting
these things constrained constrained so
uh
that like that then that's exactly the
same uh
issue here so uh uh you know like i
think
one difference would be uh this that one
won't explode because it clips out of
bounds
but my claim is the first order affect
them these are entirely
the same uh because locally
that is the first order effect you're
just clipping things when it gets out of
bounds but
they're like you know the the issue is
like nearly
uh identical uh is uh
is my claim but we're definitely doing
like a larger empirical side of things
but there's no difference here just look
just taylor's theorem what you're doing
and you'll see it's kind of the same
um the same effect
it would definitely follow up for
experiments because uh
you know i think there's australia it's
like what the heck is happening
uh in practice because we were doing
random constructions
and we were just like laughing because
all our guesses you know we're like
wrong half the time
right half that it was like uh but
it's it's it's very brittle like to say
uh the least
uh is is my uh take and then but then
there's a question of like
you know these big neo networks what's
happening too which is another set of
experiments
we're thinking about
i i'll stop here but let me just mention
that you know like
there are there are many i mean recently
i think not only my lab but also
chong liu's lab from ut austin they've
also developed this method like kernel
off
kernel belmont statistics and if you
look at their entire theory they only
assume q pi realizability
okay and then they give you like a you
know as i said they give you
intervals uh for of policy evaluation
and i think their paper has a lot of
like has quite many like uh
imperial studies across all the standard
benchmarks so i think it
may be useful to also compare and they
have neural nets and so on so forth
yeah it may be useful to look at the
their work
i mean the interval is like you know
they're gonna have the same property by
taylor's theorem
and i think the point i'm making is that
uh
you know uh your intervals are correct
under realizability
cnn like the difference is we're not
saying the intervals aren't correct and
that's what we
agree here it's just that realizability
will not get you the right answer now
some cases it might
and the whole point of like my is a
generic point which i'm not going to say
it always explodes
is trying to like i think there's too
much of saying because we can get an
interval it works
like it will not always work and now
it's an empirical question of getting a
handle
which cases are bad in which cases are
good
uh and putting the interval down isn't
telling us that
answer okay and and that's the the
distinction i'm making
here we might not agree whether or not
it works or not but the point is like uh
it definitely can amplify uh and the
intervals isn't gonna like address that
uh issue it's just gonna check it
oh i need to stop sharing
you know getting like more philosophical
with this i i don't know but so it
you know the way i would have uh some
years ago thought about features in rl
is like okay i'm modeling the value
function well
but it does seem um quite strongly from
from two papers you have here and also
from all our proofs failing uh kind of
before that
that that's not how we should think
about maybe what these are modeling
at the same time like a linear mdp
uh kind of model feels too s
or i don't know if the actual dynamics
are somehow linear
in some basis that feels too strong it's
like i
i do feel like the features should
reflect the objective
um i'm wondering how you are thinking
about
this like what do we want from features
yeah yeah i mean like look this is the
thing that actually i was talking about
wusang is like
the philosophical point is a good one
like and i think this related the policy
gradient stuff that we've both been
working on that
uh you know which is why i kind of
mentioned this point in practice like in
practice
in the sciences we tend not to build
models like we
really trust regression because uh it
tends to work well
it gives us you know confidence
intervals and there's all kinds of
problems with model miss specification
so the the more we can try to not rely
on
model uh you know try to be robust to
model this but this specification this
is needed
so that's my intuition of why we want
the cues to be linear not the model
is because uh it's just hard to get
models correct like we like even
in h equals one it's very hard to get
our actual models to be correct as
opposed to supervised learning
and the unfortunate thing here is you
know at least for the offline setting
and things in
nrl like we kind of need model-ish
things to be correct
and uh and that's kind of the the hard
part
here and and my concern is like in the
offline setting it's much harder so the
offline setting look at the end of the
day
if you can do a causal experiment you
want to do causal experiments
and this is clear from working lots of
companies and it's
you know but there is a question of like
in these scarce things we want to
squeeze as much out of the data as we
can
so uh so i don't like you know what we
want out of the future is i honestly
don't
know because um
at least when we've tried things on some
like deep learning-ish things like
um you really can get amplification
effects
and uh uh
so i'm not yeah so i'm not like totally
sure like if our goal is to get features
for offline learning that might be a
very different goal
than say solving like monozuma's revenge
because it's possible you can get
you know a preliminaries are successful
so yeah you might be able to get very
unstable features
but it's good enough for like some
incremental procedure
okay but uh whereas the features you
need here
you might need further stability
properties uh
and uh on the other hand this is like a
bit uh
warming in that like we're making these
strong assumptions for a reason
and uh pointing out like chabot's paper
a recent one like this paper is awesome
like i
you know travis here i i promised you a
beer if i believe the paper i
i owe you a beer uh chava like that
paper for linear q star
i i think also is showing that we need
much stronger assumptions i mean it's a
much more complicated lower bound
but uh um
you know i think the alluder stuff and
like what akshay is was saying the
dominaring stuff that's kind of the
closest
in between but it's far from complete
what we know